put your dead raccoon baby in a crib and
fill up on ice cream and pickles because
we're in for another hour of gaslighting
and emotional manipulation or as I like
to call it living with my ex-girlfriend
there's only one more episode left
before part one of delicate is over and
in this video we're going to take a deep
dive into the biggest questions and
theories the show has to offer keep in
mind I've not read the book this season
is based off so there won't be any
spoilers just good oldfashioned sleo
thing as always I've left timestamps
below so you can see all the topics I'll
be covering but before we begin make
sure to like And subscribe but hey it's
your body it's my body and I'll get
pregnant when I want to it wouldn't be a
great AHS season without a crazy jump in
time here we are in 1555 England with
Queen Mary the the daughter of King
Henry VII Mary never had any surviving
children from her reign in 1553 to 1558
thus the crown was passed to her sister
Elizabeth who we also see in this scene
in episode 2 we saw one of Miss
preacher's conspiracy the theories and
how it was all about Queen Mary making a
Sinister deal to secure her place on the
throne which included a sacrifice to
infernal Powers it seems this sacrifice
was her firstborn son who she delivers
to the Ashleys I know that name doesn't
sound too spooky but I really don't know
what to call them it's very much implied
that the Ashley are the Raven women from
last episode they don't age we'll see
them as an expert PR team in present day
and they can predict the future telling
Elizabeth that her time to rain will
come they also have the ability to turn
women Barren which is what they do to
Elizabeth Elizabeth too bore no children
the child itself is something these
Ashley have been waiting for for 6,000
years it's heavily implied this child is
Satan or a child of Satan with these
claw-like fingers something that's also
seen in the intro credits but we never
find out what happened to this child or
where the Ashley took him all we really
know is that they want another child and
this time it's through Anna Mary made a
deal with them to have the most fruitful
reign in England's history in exchange
for the child does this mean that Anna
made a similar deal dreams have been a
common theme throughout the season and
Anna's dream is to become a famous
award-winning actress what's worse for
your mental health a harmless app or the
death of your dream you have a peculiar
penchant for turning dreams into
nightmares together we're going to give
you the life of your dreams
unfortunately I wasn't able to get a
clear image of this lot an inscription
on the baby crib but if any of you
happen to have a super HD copy I'd love
to know what it reads Siobhan is up to
no good not only does she hire the two
Ashley's which makes me think she might
be in cahoots with them but we find out
she's sleeping with the director of
Anna's film haish this is likely how he
got Anna's address for the gift basket
last episode Siobhan gave it to him did
you tell him that I barely know this
[__] now heh and Siobhan have their
own deal going on something Siobhan
calls purely transaction there's
definitely something more than sex going
on here Siobhan mentions an interview
heish did with GQ magazine in which he
said the plot for the UR was something
that just came to him did Siobhan
actually come up with this plot did HH
make a similar type of deal for Fame in
exchange for something is sioban using
Hamish to get pregnant she did say she
wanted to have kids but her IVF never
worked but something kind of tells me
she could do something better than heish
last episode we saw Anna fixate on this
dead Rec [__] I thought this was going
to be the end of it but we see her bring
the animal into the house and dress it
in baby clothes and put it in a crib
truly Disturbing Behavior I also think
it's pretty weird that talia's basement
has a crib in it she mentioned to Anna
in episode one she hates kids and never
wants to have them so why would she have
a crib in her basement and as gums bleed
here something we found out could be a
sign of early pregnancy at the end of
the episode Anna will eat the dead
raccoon eating the Flesh and Blood of
animals is often something Satan would
do like we saw the character of Jed
Potter who was possessed by Satan due in
Asylum it's also possible that this
whole segment is a dream before this
scene we saw Anna bash her head into
this crate and get knocked unconscious I
also want to talk about the black cat it
serves no purpose to the plot whatsoever
and having a cat on set is actually a
big deal for producers since it's a big
expense to hire an animal trainer for
the day I tend to think that this was
put here for symbolic purposes as black
cats have traditionally been Associated
by being possessed by evil spirits and
that's seems to be what's happening to
Anna too Anna's upset that Dex didn't
tell her about meeting up with Sonia in
the Hamptons but he actually did tell
her in episode 2 a lie we can actually
catch Dex in however was when he says he
was with Anna when cor told them about
Miss preacher's crazy conspiracy
theories Anna actually heard about this
over the phone in episode 2 when Dex was
not with her that woman Miss preacher
that old bag don't worry about her she's
harmless so how does he know about that
was he at the Clinic was he listening in
on the conversation somehow or are
Anna's memories so jumbled we dealing
with an unreliable narrator we get our
first glimpse of dex's mom Virginia Dex
told Anna in episode 2 that her mom
lives just down the way in the Hamptons
but that she won't quote bother them
although Dex says that Virginia loves
Anna that's totally not the vibe I got
from her and good on Dex are standing up
to his mother when she starts to
badmouth her but the real mystery here
is who is dex's Dad Virginia wants to
sue him for satanic abuse she suffered
by him these are repressed memories she
helped uncover with the help of a
psychotherapist named Eugenia who claims
Virginia's husband performed Satanic
rituals does Dex still talk to his
father could Dex have learned these
rituals and performs them on Anna is
dex's Dad Dr Hill he's the only other
male lead in that age range we've seen
so far on the show and would explain
this special connection between these
two I am feeling very optimistic about
our chances why do he say that just to
you although we don't get any any Miss
preacher this episode Ivy is back to her
old tricks no one has seen Ivy but Anna
could she be in her head I also like how
she smokes something you shouldn't do
when around pregnant women a gift of
flowers arrives with a warning you can't
trust any of them only a few people know
where Anna is but honestly it could be
anyone that sent them from Nicolet Ivy
Miss preacher or even haish Anna still
hasn't gotten rid of that photo of her
husband and ex-lover Adeline to make
matters worse her face morphs into Sony
is perhaps a manifestation of Anna's
paranoia that her husband is cheating on
her now when Anna goes for a late night
craving did anyone else think it was
weird that the ice cream was in the
fridge also the combination of ice cream
and pickles is straight up satanic I
thought it was weird that Kamal joins
Anna and Dex on their trip back to New
York I thought he was talia's home
security guy but now he apparently has
his own company and has had the time to
install these creepy security sensors
all over Anna's apartment something
tells me these aren't for her safety
rather to keep an eye on her and you'd
think theyd take out that don't do it
Anna Mirror by now a constant reminder
that your house was broken into I really
have no idea what purpose Nicollet
serves she's this house manager who
doesn't even seem to know there's a
creepy satanic layer in the basement and
she's terrible at disposing of dead
animals on the property I'm also curious
why Anna hasn't shown anyone this door I
mean if I saw this thing I'd be inviting
everyone down to check it out once again
Anna is the only one to interact with
nickol that so far so it's possible she
could be in Her Imagination those were
the topics I wanted to cover today so
now I pass it off to you I want to hear
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember Daddy loves you very
much